F
COURSE HE LOVES THE POWER AND
THE WEALTH IT ALWAYS HAS AND
ALWAYS WILL.
HERE NOW WITH MORE, FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR NEWT GINGRICH.
MR. SPEAKER, I'M -- THIS IS WHAT
AMERICA LAST AND WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE WORLD IF WE HAVE A WEEK
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR GENERAL
THOUGHTS.
YOU'RE MORE OF A PROFESSOR AND
HISTORIAN THEN YOU WERE EVER A
POLITICIAN.
YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
I DON'T EVEN THINK YOU CAN
COMPARE JOE TO
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN.
NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN LOOK STRONG
COMPARED TO JOE IN MY VIEW.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
CHAMBERLAIN WAS A VERY STRONG
POLITICAL LEADER WHO HAD A
STRATEGY.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH A PERSONALITY
LIKE ADOLF HITLER, THAT STRATEGY
DIDN'T WORK.
IT'S VERY BIZARRE.
YOU HAVE BIDEN YESTERDAY SAYING
YES, PUTIN IS A WAR CRIMINAL.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS NOTHING.
YOU HAVE BIDEN SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO REALLY CUT THEM OFF AND
MAKE THE SANCTIONS WORK, AND
THEN WE LEARN FROM THE FREE
BEACON IN WASHINGTON THAT IN
FACT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS ALREADY PROMISED THE
RUSSIANS THAT IF THEY CAN GET AN
IRANIAN DEAL, THEY WILL WAIVE
THE SANCTIONS, RELEASED
$10 BILLION OF RUSSIAN
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES GOING
INTO IRAN.
ITEM AFTER ITEM.
IT STRUCK ME, I JUST WROTE A
NEWSLETTER ON THIS, BUT YOU HAD
ZELENSKYY TALKING ABOUT AN
IMMEDIATE, URGENT, NOW CRISIS
AND YOU HAVE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT
MONTHS AND EVENTUALLY AND SOONER
OR LATER AND YOU COULD TELL THIS
WHEN BIDEN SPOKE TWO NIGHTS AGO
TO THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE'S FUND-RAISER AND IN
THE ENTIRE SPEECH, THERE'S ONE
SENTENCE ABOUT UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA, AND THAT SENTENCE IS
THAT IF WE HAD MORE GREEN FUELS,
THINGS WOULD BE BETTER.
WHEN YOU CAN REDUCE THE TRAGEDY
THAT YOU AND I AND EVERYONE
WATCHING HAS SEEN IN UKRAINE,
THE VICIOUSNESS, THE WAR CRIMES,
THE BRUTALITY, AND IT GETS
TOTALLY IGNORED BY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IN HIS
SPEECH, YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING PROFOUNDLY WRONG WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, AND
FRANKLY WHATEVER IS WRONG WITH
BIDEN'S 20 TIMES WORSE WITH
HARRIS.
HARRIS' PERFORMANCE AND POLLING
WAS SO HUMILIATING TO EVERY
AMERICAN TO HAVE HER LAUGHING
WHEN ASKED ABOUT REFUGEES FROM
UKRAINE.
I WOULD SAY HARRIS SHOULD NEVER
AGAIN BE ALLOWED TO LEAD THE
UNITED STATES, BECAUSE SHE IS
SUCH A CONTINUING EMBARRASSMENT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SHE
BRINGS THE UNITED STATES IN
DISREPUTE.
NOBODY IN THE WORLD THINKS THIS
IT ADMINISTRATION CAN LEAD.
NOBODY IN THE WORLD IS GOING TO
RELY ON THE GUARANTEED OF
JOE BIDEN, WHO HAS CONSISTENTLY
LIED, LIED ABOUT AFGHANISTAN,
HAS LIED ABOUT UKRAINE.
IT'S TRULY HISTORICALLY A
DANGEROUS MOMENT FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND FRANKLY FOR
THE ENTIRE HUMAN RACE.
>> Sean: THEY ARE NOT EVEN
SERIOUS.
MAYBE YOU CAN MAKE SENSE OF WHY
THEY BROUGHT IN THE TIKTOK
INFLUENCERS INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH PRESCREENED QUESTIONS,
BASICALLY PROPAGANDISTS.
MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLAIN WHAT
JEN PSAKI COULDN'T EXPLAIN, AND
THAT'S THE LOGIC BEHIND GIVING
UKRAINE DRONES AND JAVELINS AND
STINGER MISSILES, BUT THEY WON'T
LET POLAND GIVE THEM THE MIGS
THAT THEY HAVE, AND IF YOU CAN
EXTRAPOLATE OUT THE MEANING OF
AOC'S COMMENTS, I WOULD -- I
PROBABLY GIVE IT A GOLD STAR FOR
BEING A GENIUS, BECAUSE IT MAKES
NO SENSE TO ME.
>> YOU JUST THROUGH THREE VERY
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS THAT MADE.
LET ME START WITH -- I THINK THE
WHOLE -- I THINK THE WHOLE THING
ABOUT MIGS IS NOT'S.
IF WERE GOING TO PUT IN
ANTIAIRCRAFT MISSILES TO SHOOT
DOWN RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT, IF WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE THEM EQUIPMENT TO
KILL RUSSIAN TANKS, THE FACT
THAT WE ALLOW UKRAINIAN PILOTS
TO FLY THEM OUT OF POLAND OR
GERMANY OR WHEREVER THEY COME
FROM STRIKES ME AS A NONISSUE.
WHY WOULD YOU ALLOW PUTIN TO
DEFINE WHAT YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
DO?
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT JOE BIDEN
DID.
AND I THINK THAT THERE IS NO
RATIONAL DIFFERENCE.
IN TERMS OF AOC.
LOOK, HER VERSION OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IS A RELIGIOUS
EXPERIENCE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
REALITY, NOTHING TO DO WITH
FACTS, AND AS A RELIGIOUS
FANATIC IN HER OWN RIGHT, SHE
CAN SAY ANYTHING SHE WANTS TO,
BECAUSE IT HAS TO BE TRUE,
BECAUSE IT'S WHAT HER RELIGION
TOLD HER TO SAY.
THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT TRUE
FACTUALLY MAKES NO SENSE TO
NORMAL PEOPLE AND IN FACT MANY
AMERICANS ARE BEING PUNISHED
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE BY HAVING TO
PAY VASTLY TOO MUCH FOR GAS AND
OIL AND NATURAL GAS BECAUSE OF
THE POLICIES OF JOE BIDEN.
SO IN A SENSE, THE SAID
ADMINISTRATION IS PUNISHING
NATIVE AMERICANS, NOT PROTECTING
THEM AND HELPING THEM.
I THINK THAT'S HOW I WOULD FRAME
THAT.
>> Sean: LET ME -- WE CAN LOOK
TO THE PAST.
YOU'RE THE HISTORIAN.
WE WATCHED RONALD REAGAN.
HE NEVER PUT A AMERICAN FOOT ON
THE GROUND WHEN THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION WENT INTO
AFGHANISTAN, BUT HE DID PROVIDE
THEM STINGER MISSILES, AND
THOUGH STINGER MISSILES MADE ALL
THE DIFFERENCE.
HE DID PROVIDE THE FREEDOM
FIGHTERS IN NICARAGUA THE
WEAPONRY THAT THEY NEEDED.
THAT PROVED SUCCESSFUL.
THEN YOU GOT THE TRUMP DOCTRINE,
WHICH TOOK OUT THE CALIPHATE
THAT GREW UNDER BIDEN AND OBAMA.
HE JUST BOMBED THE LIVING HELL
OUT OF THEM OR TOOK OUT -- WITH
THE SAME PRINCIPAL, NO AMERICAN
BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
AND TOOK OUT THE AL QAEDA LEADER
IN YEMEN.
I THINK WE CAN LEARN BOTH FROM
TRUMP AND WE CAN LEARN FROM
REAGAN HOW TO DO THIS AND WIN
WITHOUT RISKING AMERICAN LIVES.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> SURE.
ABSOLUTELY.
THE THING THAT'S FRUSTRATING
ABOUT THE SAID ADMINISTRATION,
WHETHER IT'S FIGHTING INFLATION
AT HOME OR DEALING WITH CRIME,
OR DEALING WITH FOREIGN DANGERS
IS WE KNOW WHAT WORKS.
WE LIVED THROUGH IT.
WE LIVE THROUGH IT FOR EIGHT
YEARS WITH RONALD REAGAN, WE
LIVED THROUGH IT FOR FOUR YEARS
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
IF THE PRICE OF OIL WENT BACK TO
WHERE IT WAS UNDER TRUMP, WE
WOULD STRIP PUTIN OF TWO-THIRDS
OF HIS DAILY INCOME.
WE WOULD CRIPPLE HIM
AUTOMATICALLY BY DOING THAT.
THE VERY FACT THAT BIDEN WOULD
RATHER BUY GASOLINE AND OIL FROM
VENEZUELA, WHICH IS A
DICTATORSHIP, IRAN, WHICH IS A
DICTATORSHIP, SAUDI ARABIA IS A
DICTATORSHIP, THEY ARE OKAY TO
JOE BIDEN, BUT NOW TEXAS,
OKLAHOMA, OHIO, PENNSYLVANIA,
NORTH DAKOTA, THEY ARE REALLY
DANGEROUS PLACES.
YOU HAVE TO SAY BY ANY
LEGITIMATE STANDARD, THESE
PEOPLE ARE CRAZY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT NORMAL
BEHAVIOR.
THEY'RE NUTS.
THEY'RE OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY, THE WORLD DOESN'T WORK
THE WAY THEY THINK IT'S GOING
TO, AND FRANKLY, I HOPE THAT THE
NEW REPUBLICAN CONGRESS IN
JANUARY WILL LOOK VERY DEEPLY AT
FOR EXAMPLE HOW WRONG OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HAS BEEN,
HOW WRONG GENERAL MILLEY HAS
BEEN -- HE WAS WRONG ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
AND THEN HE TURNED AROUND AND
SAID THE RUSSIANS WOULD BE IN
KYIV IN THREE DAYS.
HE HAD PUTIN APPARENTLY HAD THE
SAME TIMETABLE.
THE UKRAINIANS DIDN'T KNOW THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO OBEY HIM.
SO THE RUSSIANS STILL AREN'T IN
KYIV.
THAT SHOULD WORRY ALL OF US
BECAUSE WE HAVE 17 INTELLIGENCE
SYSTEMS, WE SPEND BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS, TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, AND THERE WRONG.
THIS SHOULD LEAD TO FAR MORE
THAN JUST JOE BIDEN THE
FUNDAMENTAL FORM DO